uh Pearl Pearl something bad is going to
happen to you and I don't wish for
something bad to happen to you but when
you are coming against the god-ordained
institution of marriage when it is God
the man wife and then the children and
you are trying to come against that and
you are telling men to get vasectomies
God is going to deal with you and let me
kindly remind everybody what the word of
God says about your season of singleness
in the Bible you are only called to
singleness if you can abstain from
having sex and take on a life of
abstinence so if you are not able to
refrain from sexual intercourse then you
actually are called to marriage you are
called to marriage you are called to
having children you are not called to
get vasectomies and run around sleeping
with whoever whenever and being a
heathen